you are not going alone oh no no I have
my powers to protect me
[Music]
please make sure they stay out of the
kingdom until we return
of course your parents would be so proud
of you Anna you found out the truth
about the past brought down the dam and
did the next right thing when all hope
was lost but most amazingly you did all
of this without using a shred of magical
powers you proved that you could fend
for yourself and you finally stepped
into the role you were born for you're
the queen arendelle always deserved and
Elsa's not mad about it not one little
bit she's thankful that you took that
load off her back everything is going to
change for Elsa and Anna
after frozen - but that isn't
necessarily a bad thing with Gale on
their side the sisters are never too far
away watch until the end to find out if
the spirits will reward anna and
kristoff Spurs born with powers - I
don't think Olaf should get her a ring
the new and improved game frozen - was a
story about growing up and letting go
and Elsa and Anna and the entire gang
experienced some major transformations
throughout the sequel a lot of fans
noticed that the group's dynamic hadn't
really changed between the first and
second movies Elsa was still being
secretive and withdrawn Anna was still
over preoccupied with else's well-being
Kristoff was still trying to express his
love for Anna and Olaf was still trying
to make sense of the world around him
tell me you're older in the cell knowing
do you ever worry about the notion then
provide the end of the sequel every
single one of these characters had
evolved to new heights and nothing would
ever be the same again
Elsa finally found out the truth about
her powers she's the fifth spirit and
she and Anna are the bridge between the
spirits and the humans on earth realized
that her sister needed space to be
herself and finally chose to focus on
her own life Kristoff made a human
friend and proposed to Anna and the
adorable Olaf grew up right before our
eyes everyone came into their own in
frozen - and things will never be the
same again Alice's decision for as long
as Elsa could remember she felt like the
odd one out so when a strange yet
familiar voice called out to her she
chose to keep it a secret but she
couldn't keep the secret for too long
especially not after waking up the
spirits of the forest
again also chose to disregard on his
input putting herself in danger in the
process just like grand pabbie predicted
I also went too far in the river of
memories and eventually passed away I
also thought she was protecting onna
but in reality she was pushing everyone
away once again after Anna brought down
the dam Elsa was revived but she would
never be the same again she was now the
fifth spirit and going back to arendelle
just wasn't an option
Elsa chose to stay in the enchanted
forest where she could live with the
other spirits she finally found a place
where she felt accepted a place where
she belonged but her decision to stay
back affected Anna in a really big way
the new queen of arendelle Elsa and Anna
are two very different people
and it's easy to see that Anna was
always meant to wear the crown
Elsa realized that to be her true self
she had to let go of her old life so she
abdicated the throne making Anna the new
queen of arendelle on a never once
thought that she would become Queen and
she had made her peace with that but
ruling over a kingdom is no small feat
so a lot of things are going to change
for Anna and Kristoff too at the end of
frozen two we were shown honest
coronation her people cheered as she
became their newly appointed leader you
would think that Elsa would make it a
point to be at her sister's coronation
yet Elsa wasn't there for her special
day
but Anna wasn't even fazed she
understood that her sister needed space
and realized it was her turn to let it
go
Anna learns to let it go we all know
that else is the one who coined the
phrase let it go but in frozen - it was
Ana's turn to find meaning in the ballad
Anna had spent most of her life worried
about her sister's mental health she
tried to be there for her but was
continuously shut out it wasn't until
she found out about her sisters powers
that the pieces of the puzzles began
falling into place
but even then Anna put herself in grave
danger to be there for her sister and
she did this again in frozen - I won't
let anything happen to her but now that
Elsa doesn't live in arendelle anymore
it's time for honor to focus on her own
life she isn't her sister's keeper
anymore
and she doesn't need to worry about
whether or not else is happy because she
is now that anna has learned to live and
let live she can finally be the queen
her people need and she can give
Kristoff
undivided attention the newly engaged
couple
now that Elsa is living her own life
Anna is free to do the same she can
finally focus on her relationship with
Kristoff and let's be honest
Kristoff was dying for Ana's attention
which he made painfully clear in his
hilarious number lost in the woods but
Anna was more preoccupied with her
sister than her boyfriend who kept
trying to propose to her throughout the
sequel ice unfortunately for him Anna
didn't really give him the time of day
because all she wanted to do was save
her sister from herself Kristoff is an
understanding guy he knows how much Elsa
means to honest so he supports her every
step of the way but now that Anna and
Elsa are living two parts Anna can focus
on her relationship Kristoff finally
popped the question at the end of frozen
- and honest said yes but now will their
engagement change their relationship
keep watching to find out before we
continue we invite you to join the
thanks family hit that big red subscribe
button if you haven't already and make
sure to click the bell to turn on the
post notifications this way you can be
the first to comment on our newest
frozen 2 videos if you're watching on
your phone go on YouTube settings and
turn on notifications so you never miss
another video now let's find out how
life is going to change for Kristoff and
the future king of arendelle
King Christophe Kristoff was literally
raised by rocks his best friend is a
reindeer and his social skills are
curious at best but he loves on more
than anything
why Lana would run through fire to save
her sister Kristoff would read through
fire to save his beautiful ginger
princess he's dedicated to Anna and
wants to spend the rest of his life with
her but now that Anna is too queen
Kristoff will need to become king if he
wants to tie the knot becoming the king
of arendelle was never on Christoph's
to-do list so chances are the ice
harvester is going to have a hard time
coming into his new role luckily anna is
super patient and easygoing so she'll
help Kristoff every step of the way
besides olive will encounter challenges
of her own especially since being a
queen is new to her - but if there's one
thing we know for sure it's not Anna and
Kristoff we'll be the best king and
queen arendelle could ever have hoped
for the future of arendelle three years
ago by the events of frozen one and
frozen - so that makes on at 21 years
old
at the time of her coronation both Elsa
and Kristoff are 24 years old in the
sequel obviously all three of our heroes
are still very young but now that on and
Kristoff are getting married
they'll have to think about the future
of arendelle and fast it's the King and
queens duty to supply an heir to the
throne
so eventually Kristoff and Anna will
have babies making way for the new
generation of arendelle royalty a lot
will change once the couple chooses to
have a family but we know that Anna and
Kristoff will be the best parents ever
their kids will be able to visit their
aunt Elsa and the enchanted forest
whenever they want and she'll definitely
build a snowman or two with her nieces
and nephews keep watching to find out if
odd and Christoph's kids will have any
powers of their own like mother like
daughter to say that Anna is a lot like
her mother would be an understatement
not only do they look like carbon copies
of each other but anna has her mother's
lively spirit and accepting personality
we leave now right now just like Queen
Adina Anna is selfless brave and caring
she'll do anything for the people she
loves no matter the consequences on a
now safai 'no leaf out what happened to
their parents in frozen 2 they learn the
truth about I do news heritage and used
it to connect with an authority as it
turns out I do know went against her
people to save Agner and if it hadn't
been for her actions Elsa would never
have been giving powers but whereas Elsa
was given the gifts of the fifth spirit
Anna was given the gift of her mother's
spirit and without her the Nostalgia
tribe and the people of arendelle would
still be living a lie arendelle will
never be the same
AG nurse father was terrified of magic
so much so he betrayed the nath older
tribe angering the spirits of the forest
but now that anna knows the truth she
could educate her people about the past
and teach them all about magical forces
on ik and spread love and awareness
throughout her kingdom and teach people
to not be afraid of things just because
they're different King a ganar and queen
Idina chose to keep Elsa's powers as
secrets because they were scared of how
people would react
and seal it but now that the fog barrier
has dispersed honest people can meet the
spirits and see the beauty and things
that are different and strange things
are going to change in arendelle but
Olaf learned the hard way that while
everything changes change is necessary
for growth Queen Anna
Ana's life changed very quickly at the
end of frozen - she became a queen said
goodbye to her sister and got engaged
and all in the span of a few days Anna
will have to grow up very quickly to
step into her new role but she'll always
stay true to her fun and goofy self Anna
went through one of the biggest
transformations of all time and it's
just the beginning of her brand-new
journey Anna acted very selflessly
during the sequel which probably didn't
go unnoticed by the spirit so there's a
chance that one of Anna and Kristoff
skits will be given the gift of powers -
what do you guys think will Ana's
firstborn have magical powers or not
sound off in the comments thanks for
watching
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll catch you next time on
the things
you